1500 mètres carrés de locaux neufs ici
dans la première et unique légumes riz
bio d'île de france géré par la société
aca des bio les carottes sont coupés
nettoyer épluché puis mise en sachet
direction ensuite les cantines scolaires
la destination finale la consommation
dans toute l'ile-de-france est un
circuit court complet où on gère des
filières et des approvisionnements
contractuel avec des producteurs
nous transformons les légumes pour les
rendant prêtes à l'emploi pour la
restauration collective principalement
encore en phase de lancement la
légumerie inauguré il ya un mois
profitera bientôt à près de deux cent
mille élèves une initiative francilienne
pour favoriser l'approvisionnement local
et les circuits courts
ça nécessite comme un tout petit peu de
volonté politique
elle est là une mobilisation des
collectivités locales elle est là on
avait publié des guides en a mis en
place des plans alimentaires
territoriaux tout ça ça se structurent
ça se met en place et c'est un beau
message aussi un qui consiste à dire et
bien l'approvisionnement local le manger
local
ça existe en train de se faire 1500
tonnes de légumes seront collectés
transformer chaque année en tout une
cinquantaine de producteurs vont
bénéficier de ce nouvel outil une
aubaine pour faire face aux
problématiques structurelles qui touche
le secteur agricole c'est l'avenir de
mon exploitation j'en suis persuadé
aujourd'hui voilà on est à 50 km de
paris
c'est clair que c'est un avantage
indéniable par rapport à d'autres
régions de france qui n'ont pas un
bassin de consommation aussi important à
des à proximité et c'est une véritable
chance de pérenniser mon activité
agricole pour assurer le fonctionnement
de la légumerie une vingtaine de
personnes seront employées à terme dont
la moitié en situation de handicap